alright guys bang bang I've got Mike
here I'm super excited about this
mike is one of the most thoughtful
people I think in early stage investing
and he's got all the the war stories and
scars to prove it as well so thanks for
doing this
all right Paul thanks for having me for
sure for those that don't know you maybe
let's just start with kind of your
background before you got into investing
with floodgate yeah so if we go way far
back I my first experience with business
was a professional calligrapher in the
6th grade and so I had a kind of a
natural talent for it and I learned that
I could make money much faster and with
less work by just hand labeling signs
you know menus for restaurants jewelry
store signs and stuff like that followed
my mom into town so I was in the 6th
grade and you know you'd make a lot more
money doing that than like weeding the
flowerbeds and stuff and so so that's
kinda how I got into it and then when uh
personal computers came out there was
this device called the koala pad and my
dad worked at IBM and so we weren't ever
gonna get a Mac and then you know Mac
Paint came out and so I thought well I
want to create a version of Mac Paint
that runs on PC but it's optimized for
calligraphy and so you know for folks
who understand calligraphy you you have
a wide brush that you tilt at a 45
degree angle to get that sort of the
subtlety of the beauty of the letters
and so I I got a koala pad and I had it
had it have different types of brushes
and I could do calligraphy on this koala
pad so that's how I got and then after
that started writing video games and
then went to Stanford that was just kind
of you know that was the beginning of it
yeah got it and so after Stanford did
you know that you wanted to go into
investing did you want to kind of build
at the same time how do you end up
focusing exclusively on not yeah not at
all it's funny I would not have if you
had told me nine months before I started
investing that I was going
they see some day I wouldn't have
believed it so I mean we were lucky we
had good VCS and the companies I was
involved with like when the company I
helped start in the late 90s motive had
the top people from Austin ventures
invested but also Jim Brier from Excel
at the time and so so I liked our VCS a
lot but you know to be honest I didn't
really think about him that much right
you're doing real company stuff you're
recruiting people you're trying to avert
disaster or make the quarter and you
know you obviously they give you good
advice and counsel but my experience as
an entrepreneur was not very connected
to VC at all other than their good guys
are there to try to help us so so that
one day John Thornton from Austin
venture said have you ever thought about
being a venture guy and this was when I
was thinking about what was next after
motive would public and I said no you
know I don't think I don't think I
understand the job I've never made an
angel investment before all my stock
market is index funds you know I just
don't think I know what I'm doing and so
he said well I'll just humor me you got
some time you could learn it and so I
have to admit after about six months I
got pretty darn interested and then I I
realized if I was gonna do it I needed
to move from Austin to Silicon Valley
because at the time you know it was time
to get the party started again with the
internet so you know you had what people
called web to dotto and things like that
and so I just emigrated up to Silicon
Valley fly up every Sunday night and
stay Thursday and you know my kids are
still in school so I just tried to make
something happen in Silicon Valley
though those four days a week for about
a year or so yeah and what was the
biggest difference you noticed like when
you got there given the time period this
was I think a lot of people who are
especially younger in technology or
Silicon Valley today they weren't around
men so kind of what was like the big
thing that you saw or big takeaways that
was the difference between somewhere
like in Austin and in Silicon Valley
yeah well it was interesting because
what what see
to be happening was that the web was
transitioning from a network of
connected pages to now a broader
programmable platform that was going to
connect people and have stronger api's
people have been taught about Web
Services for a few years but now you
were seeing it writ large and you know
you didn't really know what was gonna go
but you kind of had this sense that
important things were happening and
people were sick and tired of all the
bad news the dot-com meltdown and so
this is probably late 2004 early 2005
and you'd go to things like the O'Reilly
Web 2.0 conference or the emerging tech
conference and Jeff Bezos would be there
with his laptop and you know Stewart
Butterfield and F Williams all these
people ended up playing significant
roles you could have almost just written
a check for everybody that was in that
room and done well so it was just an
exciting time and it was a lot like my
early introduction to computers I wasn't
just so much interested in making money
it was just so intriguing and you the
people who were involved were builders
and they were interested in what's the
right way to do this and it was just a
really interesting magical time so that
was kind of how I got back in it there's
just a lot more of it happening in San
Francisco than anywhere else at the time
so I concluded if I was gonna be an
investor I had to there had to be an
adequate selection of companies to work
with to really make the model work got
it and then at what point do you decide
hey you know what I think I've learned
at least enough to to go out and start
floodgate and kind of what was the
original idea there well I mean part of
it was necessity was the mother of
invention so no no venture firms would
hire me you know see you could imagine
I'm this guy from Austin Texas I've
never made an angel investment before
enterprise software and I'm saying
there's this revolution happening and
the consumer internet and everybody's
like yeah that's great and you know
motive had gone public it had done
really well but nobody's Silicon Valley
care right because that's a company in
Austin and so it was a the first 18
months were kind of tough it was not
very not a very sort of helpful or
auspicious introduction but um Wow but
foundation capital August capital were
nice enough to let me spend time there
and as I was there I started to see more
and more founders wanting to raise only
a million dollars and they couldn't and
what you know not only was web to not
know happening but the way companies
were building were getting built was
changing and so when I started motive
with four other people you had to have
an Oracle database on Solaris server
hosted at Exodus and you know cost you a
year and five million dollars to start
and so I started to realize five hundred
thousand is the new five million here
you have open source software offshore
labor search engine marketing broadband
penetration and all the things that cost
us tons of money in time to build from
scratch was now off the shelf I was like
you know you're gonna be able to you're
gonna able to get product market fit for
an idea for like a tenth of the cost
that you wants good and so hey why not
why not build a fund that's optimized
right five hundred thousand dollar check
said five million dollar checks that's
you know there are a few other people
with similar ideas Josh Kopelman was
just starting a first round and in those
days were kind of kindred spirits the
two of us and Steve Anderson who ended
up working on baseline and later a few
other guys yeah and then what the name
floodgate where did that come from or
what was kind of the the genesis of that
you know we were seeking a name that
connoted the idea of an inflection so
like right at the beach so that the idea
was that come to floodgate when you feel
like you have an idea that's gonna
that's gonna create massive abundance in
the world but you want to find not just
investor but a co-conspirator so you
know I'd like to say we wanted back the
top point one percent of founders but
before the world believes and so so
floodgate was kind of like we're at a
partner with you right up into the
it's time to just open the floodgates
and then it's like we looked at people
like benchmark Sequoia kleiner perkins
Excel Greylock as our customers upstream
and so we'd be the first people on Omaha
Beach taking bullets with the founders
and then and then hopefully we could
kind of get it to the next level where
it's a little bit more ready for
investment got it and then you've made
so many great investments that I I won't
do it justice by rattling them off off
the top of my head but one of the key
themes is many of those businesses when
you invested they didn't exactly end up
doing what you had invested in right so
whether it's a Zimride and and lyft or
its octet or like you can just go kind
of down the line maybe just tell one or
two of those stories so people
understand you know what I mean by
starting out one way and pivoting and
then to kind of some of the lessons
learned or patterns that you recognized
over the years and seeing well yeah well
twitch is kind of a fun example so in
1997 or sorry 2007 I'm in a coffee shop
and I'm talking to the Weebly guy so I
just decided to invest in Weebly and
they said hey you know we like you and
we want to introduce you a friend of
ours
Justin Kahn and his team at justin.tv
and as they're saying that this guy
walks in with a camera on his baseball
cap with wires going into backpack you
know it looked like he was like a
terrorist or something with a camera on
his head and he said he sits down he
says I am Justin Kahn and I'm like great
justice nice to meet you what like what
it what's up with this
right there he goes well I'm gonna live
cast my wife at Justin TV and I say
Justin come on that's stupid right but
but like what's in your backpack and he
describes how the Internet is basically
a hostile networking environment and you
think about it YouTube it had a big exit
but it wasn't live and that it was going
to be difficult to create good live
video experiences over the Internet and
I looked at Justin and
he's just barely out of college and so
same with Kyle vote Michael Seibel and
Emmett sheer I was like you know these
guys will be anti fragile
they'll never run out of money they'll
all live in the same apartment spend
next to nothing
and it kind of doesn't matter how stupid
this idea is because the insight behind
the idea is interesting you know that
live video on the Internet's gonna be a
thing someday and I'm like you know if
the team's gonna do it I could see these
guys pulling it off you know Kyle had
the technical chops and so I think
that's one of the first lessons I've
learned is when I'm doing my job right I
realize that I'm investing in the power
of the insight rather than what is the
product for what it is right now yeah
and it feels like in those situations
you almost have to ignore what they're
telling you right in that example that
they're basically telling you something
that it sounds like you might not even
believe they can actually pull off it's
more of well if you keep that in sight
and keep pursuing that insight this will
change you almost go into it
understanding that it'll change or does
that just kind of happen and it's
unexpected when there is some pivot or
change in the future yeah well I guess
the way I look at it is a start-up is
not a company like that's the first
mistake people make is thinking that it
is both in terms of investing and
running them and I think it's I like to
call it the startup breakthrough
sequence so there's three breakthroughs
in a row the first is the insight
breakthrough and the insight
breakthrough comes from an insight from
the future and I like to believe that
great startup teams have founders who
are time travelers from the future who
are bringing the future forward to the
present starting a movement to bring the
present a head with them to many
startups today skip the insight phase
completely so they go straight to
customer development they try and go
straight to the product breakthrough
which is you know what can I build it's
unique that people are desperate for but
it's just like you know Godzilla needs
an atomic egg it needs to be radioactive
and so
you can't skip the insight breakthrough
then after that the product breakthrough
is the growth breakthrough so you kind
of you go from having an insight to the
future to having a unique product that
only you can build the people are
desperate for - now all of a sudden we
need to shift modes from MacGyver or
James Bond now we've got to be more like
mark Watney on Mars and we got a science
the [ __ ] out of it because it's about
predictable growth with a repeatable
pattern and everything we did isn't
MacGyver mode isn't it work anymore in
the growth mode mark Watney mode so it's
like you know you kind of ask yourself
okay when am i investing well I'm
investing at the beginning of the
insight breakthrough and so all I can
really evaluate is the power of the
insight and if I if I try to evaluate
much more than that and the founders I
just end up having false precision yeah
and I guess like as you think about that
insight breakthrough part of it is not
only how accurate it is but also how
important that insight is over others
right so there can be kind of small
insights or big insights how have you
seen kind of the most powerful ones is
this something that the founder they
experience and they kind of learn from
doing and then they have the aha are
they sitting in a classroom and just
thinking like like what have you seen
there in terms of where those insights
come from and then how they actually
evaluate which ones to pursue and which
ones not so I like to say there are
three broad categories I like to say
there are plausible insights possible
insights and preposterous insights and
so like most people live in the present
and so they forecast and because of that
they have projected futures but
projected futures flow from the present
and so you're not going to get much of
an insight there you're just gonna get
incremental improvements to what's
already happened and you're gonna carry
the baggage of what's wrong with the
present ahead with you so the plausible
insights an example of a founder I
worked with is Todd McKinnon
so you meet him he says hey I was VP
engineering at Salesforce I know all the
early adopter customers at cloud the
cloud is gonna be a thing there's gonna
be a lot of cloud apps customers are
having problems managing it making sense
of multiple cloud apps and so once you
hear that from him you can't really
unsee it so it's like not something that
you would have understood going into me
but once you hear it you can't unsee it
and then you say if anybody can do it
it's this guy right Eno's all the
customers it's like this is this it's
not just why is he right but what like
why is this the team that will do it
a possible insight is like Marc
Andreessen at University of Illinois or
Bob Metcalfe at Xerox PARC so they they
get into this new field and they may not
even realize it yet but they're in a
time machine so the University of
Illinois was a super computer lab with
superfast networks and they were trying
to help scientists collaborate and so
mark builds the mosaic browser web
server to make the internet useful him
and so he solved his own problem for
what was missing in the future that he
was living in Bob Metcalfe same thing he
does you know everybody at Xerox PARC
had a hundred thousand dollar computer
on their desk but if you were at Xerox
PARC that was a personal computer they
all had WYSIWYG displays and they he
connected him up on Ethernet to laser
printer and so bob was like when he
started three column of course this is
how it'll be in a few of course
everybody will have a computer on every
desk of course everybody will watch
share resources on a network and so his
his ideas about how network should be
designed going forward he just had a
superior understanding of the future
because he was already been living there
so you know William Gibson I don't know
if you've ever read Neuromancer but you
know he says the future is already here
it's just not evenly distributed and
then the third type preposterous is Elon
Musk so the guy says I'm gonna do a
rocket company and launch rockets into
outer space and have them come back and
land to be reusable when nobody's ever
done that except a government agency
called NASA
I mean other countries can't even do it
other than the Russians and maybe a few
others an Ilan decides him to start
company to do that or he starts electric
car company when there hasn't been a
successful car company in 50 years and
like that they've made a famous movie
called Tucker to celebrate the most
recent abject complete failure of a new
car company so now people think that
he's crazy but actually Elon is the
right kind of crazy because when he's
talking about first principles what he's
really talking about is inflections that
are coming together and in all cases
regardless of the insight they're almost
always in my experience powered by
inflections that create exponentially
improving outcomes that are the rock in
the slingshot of the entrepreneur so the
entrepreneurs like David he defeats a
Goliath by putting an insight into a
slingshot slinging it out of them so
that's you know Elon understood that if
you pulled together battery technology
which was approving sensors AI Big Data
compute capacity all of a sudden it
became possible to pull all those pieces
together into an electric car or rocket
yeah it's like as part of this is having
the insight is both the easy part and
the magic right you gotta have the right
insight it's got to be a big enough idea
but it's also got a beat on the right
time horizon too right we've been
talking about you know we're gonna put
computers in each other's brains for you
know decades at this point and if you go
back 20 30 years those people literally
were considered crazy now people are
like that's probably going to happen but
you know not next year and really
somebody's gonna probably build a big
company at some point around that idea
it's just understanding when and so how
do you think about like why now or it is
now the right time it's it's a great
question so and this is where why we
think inflections are so important so we
like to say there are four types one is
technology
which is like Moore's law or you know
sequencing a genome the next is an
adoption inflection you know X number
people use Bitcoin now five years from
now
10x will or 100x or thousand X will the
third is a regulatory inflection you
know now telemedicine can be practices
across straight state lines will that be
permanent you know new spectrum becoming
available for communications and then
the fourth is a belief inflection and a
belief inflection might be you know now
I kind of think I would like to do most
of my doctor's appointment so I'm
telling this and now that I've had to do
it a few times it's not so bad
and you know doctors and patients are
starting to think that so like a good
wine example from a company we invested
in lift the technology inflection was
the GPS locators in smart phones became
ten times more accurate with the iPhone
3GS it but if you had if you'd had the
idea for lyft or uber but you tried to
launch it before that was true wouldn't
it matter that your idea was right it
would have been too early because the
service wouldn't have worked right but
then the other component of the why now
was the adoption inflection we could say
okay it's 2010 10% plus or minus have
smartphones will more than 50 percent
have smartphones in three to five years
or like that you know you could see that
being possible so you say okay now let's
let's look out into a world where most
people have smartphones that you can
locate precisely maybe now you can
create a transportation network but
whereas you couldn't have done it before
and if you'd waited another couple years
you'd have been too late somebody would
have gotten the jump on you and built a
network effect before you could have
yeah and then I guess the last part of
this kind of insight component is how
big the insight is right and and the
reason why that's important is if you
think about there's a lot of investors
who they just say look the right markets
the team can be actually subpar the
market will win and kind of carry a
subpar team maybe a little bit of an
exaggeration and you
you know above average team in a great
market so one would love to know your
opinion on that but also to just how do
you know that this market will be big
enough if they can actually pull this
off where it can drive the types of
returns that make the power loss of a
venture fund work yeah so the first
thing I'd like to say about market is
when it comes to startups most people in
my view misinterpret what a market even
really is so in a company people tend to
look at a market as something that you
can map it's like I'm Lewis and Clark
I'm gonna map all the tributaries of the
Mississippi River and I'm gonna say how
high the mountains are where the trees
are all this stuff where the Indians are
you know where where the arable land is
that's that is a way to think of markets
if you're living in the present working
at a big company startup markets or
movements and movements are started by
time travelers living in the future
coming back to the present with a secret
about the future and they enlist other
people initially who believe their
secret and they start a movement and the
market is a consequence of the movement
accelerating and so as more and more
people start to buy into the insight of
the founder of the visionary founders
the conventional wisdom and belief
shifts to the point of view of the
founders and then there's this tipping
point where the market tips and now
people in the present think that's a
market they start mapping it they do all
the traditional things but so the the
reason that I think that's important is
that the mistake that I think some of my
fellow investors make is they ask what's
the town you know the total available
market and I'm like that's a myth when
you invest in a start-up there there is
no market the question is is the insight
powerful enough that a massive movement
could start around it that will change
the world and so the inside is like the
Archimedes lever of that founder who's
going to move the world and they're
going to start out small and by the way
most people
to disagree with him at first right good
insights most people won't like it
because most people look at the present
so you're trying to you're trying to the
best startups I have ever been involved
with our founders in on a secret that's
right
venture people who believe their secret
early customers who believe their secret
and they all go to war together and make
this mission happen which becomes this
gathering movement and and in the market
itself is the accumulated enthusiasm and
energy behind the movement yeah one of
the best ways I've heard this
articulated is almost like this market
expansion component right if you go back
to the lyft or uber with ride-sharing if
you just looked at it and said oh they
can go after taxis that's actually a
pretty small market compared to what
they ended up doing right they ended up
actually there's a lot of people who
don't have cars now they did going after
black cars and going after taxis right
there's so many different things that
they were able to almost take a market
and double or triple it probably in size
if not more and that's really hard to
sit there with a spreadsheet early on
and you know kind of find some numbers
that tell you that story you almost have
to have a gut belief that that can
happen which i think is kind of your
idea of this movement to some degree
yeah you know and like too many people
make the mistake at least in startups of
thinking of markets as static that it's
the thing I need to discover as if it's
already there but but startup founders
who are great understand that the future
is designed by people with sort of a
determined deliberate view of what the
future should be and they realize that
the future doesn't happen to us it
happens because of us and the decisions
that we make and so you're not going to
part of part of the vocabulary of
product market fit this I find
problematic is it's as if the markets
there I need to find it somehow with the
product but product market fit is more
of like a dance and it's like you as the
entrepreneur or the lead and the market
follow your lead by creating this
movement that
it goes back and forth in this dance but
um that's to me that's the thing that
and we need more entrepreneurs like that
who are understanding that the future is
what we make of it that like design is
not just a word for making things look
good or even making products that look
good the future is what we designed
design is a word writ large in my in my
view for sure I've heard you tell the
story of I think was EV Williams and
Twitter and like running out to your car
to get the check maybe explain that
story a little bit and kind of how when
you talked with them it sounds like you
made a pretty quick decision and new
relatively early like hey this is
something I want to bet on right it
wasn't
let me run back to the office and spend
six weeks and do a bunch of due
diligence and all of that at least from
what I understand from the story yeah so
so well they're two different ones so
Kevin Rose was the one where I went out
to the car so so this was dig and I was
really interested in citizen journalism
and so I like to say if I'm doing my job
well I've done all the diligence on the
company for the most part before I ever
met the founder because if I'm following
inflections
I have a little bit of a sense of what
what what types of valuable businesses
might be built some day that haven't
been built yet so you know like with
with Kevin I already knew who did was I
was super excited and at the time I had
no reputation at all the valley and so I
heard Ron Conway was this awesome angel
investor so I took him to lunch and I
said just give me one chance to look at
one project with you that's all I want
just one chance all I need and so he
said okay whatever you know you get your
chance and so I said you know I imagine
that you're gonna be talking to this
company Digg I'm a huge fan I know
exactly what's up with it I really want
to see dig with you so we met Digg I
told Kevin and Jay that if if they
didn't let me invest I'd go a hunger
strike there
which pride different tactic than most
use with with EV it was I'd invested in
OTO and a week after my check cleared
Apple decides to give podcasting away on
iTunes for free and at the time they had
monopoly and playback devices so quickly
we understood audio wasn't going to be a
business and and you know some investors
were kind of disenchanted and so I have
to agree to give everybody their money
back which was just amazing gesture and
and I said look at but yeah you don't
owe me anything it's you know you win
some you lose some
he said well actually I'm kind of
contractually I need to give it back to
you and then he describes this thing
they're working on
he's like Jack is working on this thing
with us called uh we're either gonna
call voicemail 2.0 or twt TR and I asked
him what it does he says did you say
what you're doing and what else 140
characters or less this is before the
iPhone and uh and I remember leaving I
said okay I want to invest in it
whenever you turn it into something he
goes what it's not a company yeah I said
well I want to write a check whatever I
have a chance and I went away from that
meeting thinking okay maybe I've lost it
for sure now but then it blows up at
South by ironically in Austin where I'd
come from and then uh and then I have
caught reaches out one day it says were
you serious it now's the time if you
want to do it and by then and Twitter
was becoming a thing it was I was afraid
of he was gonna have forgotten that I
wanted in so it was very gracious of him
the whole way in so like Twitter's a
great example first of all it's an
amazing story with the hunger strike I
think that that is definitely one way to
win and hopefully other investors don't
take away that that they should start
going on hungers yeah it's not something
I'd recommend cause it only works it's
called like maverick a Top Gun you know
you like it a one-time maneuver kind of
thing for sure but like with Twitter for
example when it was still just TW CTR
what was the insight as to why you
wanted to invest right so literally they
said hey we're gonna go after this first
thing o do it doesn't work here's your
money back
and it sounds like really they kind of
just described it over the phone almost
and you knew that you wanted to invest
was it the team was it something that
they had said in the pitch around like
the insight would just help me unpack
that it was um it was kind of a somewhat
of a combination of a belief and an
adoption inflection and I I didn't have
the insight to understand the impact of
the iPhone was gonna have but F
basically said to me look before I did
audio for podcasting I did blogger you
know he wrote this blogger software he
got about a million people writing blogs
and he goes you know podcasting is
harder it's you know you as you know
it's you just have to do more work you
have to know more things particularly in
2005 and so he says you know I figured
maybe we should just go in the total
opposite direction and if people could
write microblogs it would be so easy
that it but just imagine if ten million
people did micro blogs and if ten
million people do it then the burden of
proof is on the people who are negative
because then you've got something to
build on and I was like you know I think
he's right and so and at the time I was
like I just felt a lot of confidence in
them as people and so I just thought you
know that's right it's a first
principles exponential type of insight
but I'd love to say that I was smarter
than that that it was you know is pretty
dang lucky there's a little bit of luck
in everything now before we go on to uh
some of the building stuff you recently
wrote a piece on bat casting so maybe
talk a little bit just like what that is
and and part of the argument that you
made in that in that piece yes so the
the the idea was is it is it possible to
apply theory to creating massive
breakthroughs and so a lot of people
tend to say well yeah it's easy in
hindsight to say oh yeah Bill Gates was
awesome or you know Larry Page Mark
Zuckerberg but that's you know
survivorship bias and there's some truth
to that right if all you do is analyze
the winners you don't analyze the losers
who didn't show up but here's where I
think the theory comes in my theory is
that basically inflections drive
exponential opportunity and that there's
a cause-and-effect relationship and you
know Moore's Law Metcalfe's law all
these different exponentially improving
factors give them enough time and
they'll breach the advantage of any
incumbent so the magic of the tech
industry is it guarantees us a
continuous supply of amazing awesome new
kick-ass companies someday that blow
things up and so like the it's it's
almost like the gathering power of the
entire ocean underneath you when you
surf right and and so the back casting
the theory goes you want to take a set
of inflections out into the future with
you and then map those inflections
imagine like the future is like a cone
and like the possible outcomes or the
plausible outcomes or at the center of
the cone and then the possible or like
further out in the cone then
the preposterous even farther and so now
you're you're it's like this future map
of the future and you're trying to
locate insights you breathe armed with
these inflections that you believe are
going to be powerful you try to talk to
fellow time travelers and tease out
secrets about the future and these
secrets these erm secrets or insights
and what I like to say is that there's
no absolute best insight there's sort of
the the best insights very personal it's
about founder market fit and every every
insight is a risk-adjusted bet about the
future that the people the present don't
believe and so Elon is willing to go way
out there and make preposterous looking
bets to the present but you know he ends
up being right and so like that's what I
like to say is like an insight is like a
bet it's a bet on a future that most
people don't see but it's also a bet on
you and like your confidence in your
ability to be the person and the team to
make that insight real and I like to say
on some level and insight if you look at
it through
financial academia it's an arbitrage
it's an arbitrage between your
understanding your better understanding
of the future and somebody living in the
present who can only predict project
forward and even though your likelihood
of failure is high your risk adjusted
return is higher because the upside is
asymmetric yeah it almost feels like
there's this balance between taketake
Ilan with the electric vehicle or the
rocket there's probably plenty of people
who said hey Rockets are expensive right
and they don't quite get to well the
idea of a reusable rocket so then some
people gets a reusable rocket but they
say well there's no way to do that right
how are you gonna reel and a rocket and
you kind of it's almost like a funnel
where at the top of the funnel there's a
lot of people that understand maybe the
problem but as you get kind of towards
the bottom of the funnel people end up
opting out and saying either it's not
possible they don't know the solution or
they can't build it at the very very
bottom of that it feels like there's
somebody like Elon who says not only do
I have this insight but also to your
point I can build it right into me like
that's the that's the disconnect that I
think you see is like there's plenty of
people who have the ideas but the belief
in being able to execute it I think
really sounds like that separates people
from that you know the best from
everyone else I think so you know the
way I like to see it is there's people
living in the present which is most
people and there's a small set of people
who are out there living in the future
but the interesting thing is when I talk
to people living in the future I very
rarely ask them well what kind of a
product do you think is gonna happen
because they don't want to think that
way like a futurist is like well no you
know like there's gonna be a sensor you
know there's gonna be a sensor free
currency that's throughout the world it
is you know independent of all
governments that's just if you say okay
well great what's the first step to that
happening what you realize through time
is it's not a good question to ask them
it's it's not a question they'd like to
hear it's not a question they have any
expertise in and so you have this
impedance mismatch you have people
living in the
present who can't see the future you
people living in the future who can't
relate it to the present and don't
desire to so I like to say the
entrepreneurs job is to come from the
future to the present and pull people in
a structured way to the future and and
so back casting is all about rather than
projecting for the present - what the
future will be you go to the future you
work backwards and imagine the steps
backwards through time it's like you're
at the top of a tree you see the tops
and so you can look down and see all the
branches I have to climb up the tree to
get to the top if you start at the
bottom of the tree you may climb what
looks like obvious branches and you're
out on a limb and you can't get now you
can't get to the top of the tree and so
great entrepreneurs are able to to sort
of reconcile the impedance mismatch they
go from the future to the present to the
future to the present and they can have
the right conversations with all those
people along the way because not just
what you build it's your your persuasive
abilities right and getting people to
want to change from their present state
of comfort yeah and I guess part of this
too is like I almost envision there's a
visual of like I know where I'm going in
terms of maybe not the finish line but
but kind of the Waypoint that I'm headed
towards and figuring out from where I am
to there as part of the the company
building or the entrepreneurs job how do
you think about the best people their
ability to kind of constantly check if
they're headed in the right direction
and specifically one of the things that
I've seen a lot is like now that there's
so much data available it's really easy
to use data to optimize for almost the
wrong things rather than kind of where
you originally set out to go so how have
you seen some of the better
entrepreneurs navigate that because you
would think data is actually a benefit
but sometimes it can be too almost a
distraction yeah it's interesting like
what I find is that most most
entrepreneurs seem that that have been
great are pretty firm about the future
but flexible and pragmatic
the present and so they know that they
have to convince people to go on a
journey with them and so you know I like
to say if you look at Star Wars as like
a metaphor the entrepreneur isn't Luke
Skywalker the entrepreneurs like Yoda
and you you say hey look I have this
mystical set of powers and tools that's
gonna help you get from the world of the
day to a better world of tomorrow but
they have to be practical because they
have to persuade those people and people
people don't like to change even then
they're uncomfortable that even when
people feel pain often they're
comfortable in their present state of
pain because they're used to it and they
don't like to change because it gets
them out of their comfort zone and so
the best founders I've worked with are
somewhat rigid about their view of what
the future is and it's not even rigid
it's more just it's inevitable and I and
I could ask this sometimes when I
started floodgate or you know I've been
an entrepreneur of the past people would
say to me things like well there weren't
really any seed funds at the time what
would you have done if you couldn't
raise money and it never occurred to me
I wasn't gonna raise the money and you
know it's funny because I couldn't even
spell LP but it was just completely
obvious to me that like that wasn't the
question that mattered at all the
question that mattered was how soon are
we gonna back thunderlizards when
they're lean startups that was that was
what mattered and so what I find is that
a lot of the founders that I've talked
to have been who've been effective they
talk about the future like it's real
today and it's like it's like they see
it it's not a hallucination it's just
inevitable and there's an inevitability
about the founder where you're just like
wow you know this person that they're
gonna do it there may happen yeah and
make it's part of this you know I've
been fortunate to to be around a couple
of these these entrepreneurs you know
especially at Facebook we're just there
was a top executive team where everyone
was like that right you know you were
kind of mad
it's to each other if you will but that
to me when I would hear them talk there
was an element of they were very humble
they're very realistic but they were
very confident in kind of a positive way
that they were going to be able to
accomplish whatever its that they set
their mind to you balance that with
sometimes you hear founders pitch and be
that confidence it's actually a level of
arrogance to some degree and how do you
kind of filter between you know who is
being pragmatic versus whose almost like
saying the things that they think
they're supposed to say and yeah and
trying to like decipher you know where
to put the chips when you make those
bets and not almost get fooled by some
confidence that ends up you know being
pretty shallow yeah usually the people
who are overly confident to the and even
arrogant can't back up their insights
and when you when you ask them when you
push them they just wave their hands you
know they they just haven't been
thoughtful you know they haven't gone
down the idea amaze at all they just
sort of and when you when you ask them
reasonable cause and effect questions
they they kind of their responses well
you're just stupid and whereas what I
find is the great founders sometimes
they are pretty arrogant but they are
tough minded about what are the critical
insights that that power their business
and what are the must do things that
have to happen they're almost like
Pareto like in their approach to life
Andy Radcliffe a former like benchmark
had this great anecdote that he told me
when I first got into business when he
was a VC he would sometimes ask a bunch
of questions to founding CEO and if the
founding CEO answered every question
thoroughly he didn't invest and the
reason is that the founding CEO was
better at doing their to-do list than
prioritizing and so what he wanted was a
founder to say look if you want me to do
and I
turn this I will but like of the 10
questions that you asked these are the
two that really matter
so I went really deep on these two and I
just did a barely good enough job on the
others because I really rather talk
about these two and why they matter and
what what Andy tells me is that time and
again those are the founders that win
because you just can't do it all it
can't check off everything on the list
and so you have to do that you got to
get an A+ it's a small number of things
even if you get a D at everything else
rather than a B+ at everything yeah it's
it's so funny to hear the best investors
say the same you know 5 to 15 patterns
they just all articulate it a different
way but those little things of just
knowing what to focus on and being
determined to see it through kind of
stick out through all these
conversations I want to switch gears a
little bit and talk about Cogan 19
obviously as raging on as we're
recording this what are you guys seeing
kind of on the ground with these precede
and even some seed companies that the
virus is either changing you know things
that they're doing or to maybe markets
that you mentioned telemedicine that
maybe previously weren't there or you
guys weren't excited about that now me
may start to be ripe for someone to go
ahead and and really build a big company
yeah so so there's there's a few areas
that I think are interesting distributed
health care we can come back to that I
think that changes in regulation and and
then just the overall problem of the
cost ineffectiveness of our health care
system I think create an opening I think
that education you know now we're all
finding out what it's like to homeschool
our kids and on some level we may not
never want to do that again and never do
remote education but I think on another
hand we're starting to understand what
works what doesn't work related is
remote work infrastructure and so I
think a lot of companies thought of
remote work as you know distributed work
is something that I might let people do
some of the time
but now I think people are going to be
more willing to have it be a mainstream
way real oka lysing supply chains I
think is interesting and particularly
with 3d printing and advanced
manufacturing the other thing though
that I've just been thinking about a lot
is just kind of this this idea that the
government seems to be you know whether
they want to or not becoming an
increasing fraction of our GDP and that
that worries me a little bit but I also
have to be reality-based about it so I
could I could see a world where the
government in order to involve in order
to avoid deflation starts to fund back
to work projects sort of like at the end
of the New Deal and if you believe
that's gonna happen you could you could
maybe squint and see a possibility that
some hard tech you know around
transportation climate change could get
funded that would have been more
challenging for traditional VC to fund
in the past and so all of those areas I
described I think have different belief
inflections technology inflections but
but I think mostly it's accelerating a
future we were already headed to just a
little quicker yes so you mentioned both
remote work and I'll call remote
education are kind of homeschooling
those seem to have a lot of overlap
because the infrastructure may be
positioned for different use cases but
for the most part there's everything
from communication to literally the
ability to videoconference and do all
that how are you guys thinking about
kind of what level of the stack to
invest in almost right is it something
where you look at it as more of
platforms and marketplaces is it
something where you take up like an
existing service let's say like tutoring
and you just bring that online and in a
better way you know when you evaluate
that like what is that framework look
like to you yeah well it's funny for me
always
does start with inflections and so so
for example you know I've been I've been
reading a lot lately about like the
passion economy and people becoming
solopreneurs and being able to be in
business for themselves which I love all
that stuff totally agree but the way I
would come at a question like that is to
say what are the inflections technology
adoption belief or regulatory that
startups will be able to use as a force
multiplier to get a wedge into the
market because you can believe that the
passion economy is gonna happen but the
beneficiaries are incumbents like
YouTube and Instagram and you know
Amazon and you know the people that make
fancy camcorders and stuff like that and
so for me it's it's not enough to say
that that you know people coming back to
work or want to do therefore things I'm
like okay I agree or that there's a
skill gap in the economy I agree you
have to you have to connect that to a
change event that's bigger than any one
startup but that a startup uses is
asymmetrically powerful weapon and I
found that that that um that approach to
things has felt durable for me in every
market I've ever been part of you know
like here's another example people say I
want to sell you know eldercare you know
now is the opportunity for eldercare
startups I'm like I agree
what's the inflection that lets a
start-up win there rather than just
traditional companies extend their
product lines or sell more of their
products so to me it always comes back
to the inflection that's the that's the
magic that animates startups it almost
feels like as you're evaluating the
insight you know the three insights you
just said or I want to say generally
accepted but definitely they're not new
ideas right even to the point where
you're saying hey I agree with you that
that is a directional insight that makes
sense
how important is it for the actual
insight the founder has to be
or nuanced than almost non-consensus
verses it to be a consensus idea but
they just you know they have a nuanced
perspective on it or they can just out
execute people yeah well and you know
your mileage may vary as an investor
right so there are plenty of investors
who would do a totally different set of
things than I do and they can be right
right so it's kind of like it's kind of
like what's your checklist and what's
your access to the good opportunities
but uh I guess the way I the way I look
at it is it's funny I get pitched a lot
by people and and they'll they'll tell
me their idea and I'll say well you know
I think it should have some inflections
and I can't see those yet can you
describe them to me and very often they
can't and and and so sometimes the
response I get is well starting with
inflections is obvious you're not
telling me anything I didn't know and
I'm like okay great what are your
inflections and they don't have an
answer right it's so like I guarantee if
you if you say I don't know how many
pitches you look at these days from
founders but I guarantee you if you said
what are your fundamental insights most
don't have a good answer and so I'm like
just because it's obvious doesn't mean
people do it and so so I got like for me
I'm just kind of simple I'm like if
there's not an insight there I get
uncomfortable but part of what I'm doing
is I'm trying to provide a surface to
the founder because what I find is that
when sometimes a founder has an insight
and they just haven't put a voice to it
and when they can put a voice to their
insight then they understand in a Pareto
optimal way oh this is where my real
advantage is gonna come from this is the
part that I need to stick the landing
whereas this other stuff now that I
think about it's important but it's not
vital the way this is over here because
that's where my weapon comes from that's
where my asymmetric upside comes from
and so I like to say you either have
insights that you haven't figured out
yet or you you just don't have any and
then you ought to ask how do you feel
about that you're about to go to war for
this startup idea how do you feel about
that
it almost feels like it's also a filter
for persistence in some degree as well
right to your point of like if you don't
have insights and you're running into
the battle at what point are you like oh
wait a minute this you know this is
combat this is not fun I want to turn
around and go home versus if you have
that true insight and you really believe
the world is gonna look this way and
that inevitability to it it helps you
whether some of those tough days and the
downturns that sort of just you know is
going to go through regardless of how
great the founders are so like you know
love conquers all in a startup right and
it's like you know all startups are
impossible and you're gonna get punched
in the face over and over again you're
gonna have people telling you your ideas
stupid you have all these near-death
experiences you're gonna have bad luck
come at the worst times
you're not founders arguing about which
way to go and so if you don't have
authentic love for the insight and a
determination to make it true in the
future you'll give up you know you'll
quit when it gets that hard whereas you
know love conquers all and so you know I
think that that's really important and
what I find is that that people who who
have an insight about how the world
should be find it very hard to let go of
that they find it very hard to unsee
that or let go they just have to see it
come true yeah well I saw a tweet
recently that you had where you're known
as a good one
you've basically liked the fact that all
of these younger people are being sent
home essentially to their to their
bedrooms right and they've got a lot of
time to think they're not distracted
with their friends or kind of the
traditional experience of school it
actually may lead to a lot more
invention right they've got time to
think and kind of maybe describe a
little bit about why you think that's so
important I tend to agree with you but
I'll just unpack it a little bit more in
terms of what you meant by that
yeah so most of most great founders that
I've met I've also learned in their past
they built something for its own sake
not because they were going to
quarks credit not because they're gonna
get an allowance not not for any
extrinsic motivation purely intrinsic
and they did it just because they got
obsessed with a new field and in fact a
obsession is a word I like when it
relates to founders and you know it rubs
some people the wrong way but to me
obsession is like you just it's the last
thing you think about before you go to
bed it's the first thing you think about
when you get up and when you're when
you're in a situation like a lot of
these fourteen-year-old kids are in now
they have time to kind of go off into
their room and put the keep out sign on
the door and pursue an obsession at a
degree of a level of intensity that they
might not ordinarily be able to do and I
think that's a good thing so I think
that we're gonna find a lot of
inventions and breakthroughs from people
who didn't know what the rules were
supposed to be will come out of this
period yeah it's um we hope so at least
for sure one of the things you guys did
a floodgate recently that I thought was
pretty cool is you create the anchor
list and is very focused I think got
operators and founders maybe talked a
little bit about what that is and kind
of the logic behind starting that yeah
so that you know what you find is behind
a lot of these startups is some
operators who everybody who was involved
with the success looks back on it says
I'm not sure it would have even happened
without them and they're usually kind of
the unsung heroes or serve like the
offensive lineman and a football team
you know and so these operators can be
enormous ly helpful to startups and so
we wanted to start to have a very highly
curated list of who we thought the best
startup operators are which is important
because a lot of big company operators
provide precisely the opposite of good
advice to startups and so Shawn who's
our senior associate is kind of heading
this up is very passionate about
and so we've gotten some really good
judges and we're trying to identify the
best operators who can help startups and
just see where it goes from there
if nothing else they get recognized that
if if it goes beyond that so much better
absolutely in speaking of operating I
kind of want to end with a conversation
around the investing business itself is
changing right and so a lot of people
want to ask investors about the cool
companies they find and their process
for finding those companies but for
those that do invest they realize
there's a whole other part of the job
that usually doesn't get talked about
which is building floodgate running
floodgate and kind of thinking about
your own business what are those changes
that you guys you know behind closed
doors are talking about and kind of
cognizant of as to how your business is
changing as technology you know improves
and the virus you know what kind of goes
and all that yeah I think that the the
thing we always try to come back to is
all great investing is about knowing
something the market doesn't know and so
it's not enough just to say hey we were
early we've got a good brand let's jump
into the strong and try to win our share
and so we're always pushing each other
to say what is your idea that's not
obvious because like right now you know
it's funny you'd think that seed pricing
is going to go down all this stuff
there's a good argument that it's going
to go up you know the series a firms and
the bigger firms there'll be less
inclined to do series B and C rounds
unless it's an overtly obvious
compelling company Aleksei notion and
then they could just back up the truck
and park a lot of money in it but semi
risky B in C rounds I think are gonna
get done less and I think that the big
firms are gonna say well you know
writing a two million dollar check
doesn't feel that risky to me if I have
a billion dollar fund and so I think we
might see more seed checks in the short
term and so if you think your business
is just jump into that scrum and try to
fight for your share deals
I don't think that that you can ever be
very good I mean I think you can do okay
but I don't think you could you you end
up having a strategy that's based on
fear missing out whereas I think that
what you you can still say well you can
always have an idea that's not obvious
and you can always find startups that
embody those non-obvious ideas and be
non-consensus and right as an investor
or not just a entrepreneur and I believe
that you can always do that
that there's always a new frontier of
getting good at that there's always an
opportunity that the market doesn't see
there's always groupthink in markets
it's always true and so you know
hopefully we can hopefully we can do
that it's but it's tempting right we
start to say gosh we don't do as many
events as this firm over here should we
have a recruiting agency or should we
you know have all these platform
services and marketing programs and
newsletters and you know it's a every
now and then if you're not careful you
get caught up in should we do that yeah
a very experienced angel investor once
said to me this game is easy you just
have to see everything and then be able
to get in the deals that you want and I
said that sounds really easy but
obviously incredibly difficult to to be
able to do and it feels like there's a
lot of you know the ground is moving a
little bit in early stage investing some
of it from the better some of it not but
you know to your point more and more
people have newsletters more and more
people you know want to make sure
they're top of mind and it's almost a
sense of what you described with
founders making sure they're focused on
the right things right and kind of
letting everything else just be it
sounds like you guys kind of go through
that exercise yourselves yeah and we try
to be friends with you know anybody
who's got new ideas of how to invest you
know a lot a lot of the operator angels
you know folks like Jeff Morris Brianne
Kimmel Bobby good lot Ryan Dell lots of
these folks we've we've decided rather
than think of it as a competitive threat
or have a defensive posture we should
just say hey there are fact and let's
let's help them and and be
friends and work on projects together
find a way to be good for the ecosystem
together and so you know I think that
you can do that and still still come out
ahead but you know it's it's it's it's a
lot harder than it was in 2005 in 2005
it was hard to convince people that it
was even worth doing but now you got
like eight hundred and some-odd seed
funds and climbing you know now it's now
it's uh I like to say when you invest
you got to decide do you have fear
missing out or do you have joy of
finding greatness and and so I'm more of
a Jo FG sore you know I'm like it's okay
if I don't see all the good ones as long
as the stuff I spend my time on is great
and as long as the people I'm in
business with are really great you know
I'll get my share and I'll just get
comfortable with fact that I can't see
it all well you uh you've got the
podcast the starting greatness and
you've brought on you know great guests
after great guests and I joked with
somebody recently I said Mike's cheating
he gets to talk to all the smartest
people in the world already now he's
just gonna show it off to everyone I'm a
podcast it's been fun I uh you know if I
was smart about it I'd be a little more
calculating I'd be like figuring out the
release schedule and how to game it so I
get traffic and stuff but I thought okay
if I could if I could have just the the
people who are the super performers and
talk about what it was zero to one that
that would just be that would be a good
thing to put out there and so I've just
had tremendous fun with it it's the
people that are coming down the pike are
gonna be pretty fun too
I've got one coming out a few days now
with Steve Blank on kovat 19 that it's
gonna be a little bit controversial
because you know we take some pretty
extreme positions in it but what the
heck you know it's it's the truth as we
see it it's as you know many of these
cases you can optimize the little things
like release schedules for the end of
the day
contents good that's you know 80 90
percent of the value right and kind of
people will find that the good stuff
regardless of if you release it at
midnight or some other time yeah I hope
so and I mean that's what we've so far
it's just been less but better as trying
it is how we're trying to think about it
and you know top time will tell and even
if we never get a deal because of it
it's just been fun and it's a fun fun
way to connect with founders throughout
the world and it's just you know 155
countries have downloaded it it's just
way way more than I ever would have
expected for sure if people want to go
find out more about you or a floodgate
where do you want to send them website
Twitter yeah probably the best place to
Twitter at em to junior the podcast is
starting greatness so that's on Apple or
Spotfire where you know wherever and
then your website's floodgate com
but yeah I mean and and I like to engage
with folks particularly people who have
these there are these Time Traveler's
with these insights from the future you
know those are my peeps for sure so
before I let you go I asked two
questions and then you get to ask me one
to finish the first question is what is
the most important book you've ever read
gosh one that has been poignant for me
recently has been the top five regrets
of the dying and it is this woman named
Bronnie ware who was in Australia and
she would help people in hospice the
last 90 days to six months of their
lives and she she filed found out from
these people what are the things they
wish that they'd done in life that they
didn't get around to or that they just
you know I wish I had been my authentic
self I wish I had been not afraid to
express my feelings I wish that you know
so there's a set of things I wish I
didn't work so hard and so if the book
is really nicely done because it has an
example of somebody dying who's pissed
because they they miss
this and they have no time left and then
there will be somebody who did it right
and they you know they they sort of end
up having no regrets
and so that book was helpful for me
because it was like you know you get so
focused on winning the here and now that
sometimes you got to come up for air and
say okay if if I'm in the last 15
seconds of my life am I gonna be like oh
[ __ ] I've you know I have one of these
five regrets so I like that a lot I like
books like that I don't read business
books as much you know I've always liked
this book called The Alchemist you know
and I like a lot of Dumas books so the
Count of Monte Cristo is such a good
writer but yeah I don't I don't read as
well I read three books a week so is it
like depends of business and other stuff
but most of the stuff that sticks with
me is longer term yeah I think it's a
Bezos as the one who basically said you
know most of the big decisions in his
life the way he decides what to do is he
says I fast forward you know tell him 80
years old and then look back and say
which decision am I gonna regret the
most not making up and then he goes
ahead and he does it and so a very
similar type of Mines out there and
every company I've ever started I was
way more afraid of what it would feel
like when somebody else does it then am
I gonna fail like it it just you know in
racing the fast race car drivers say you
don't look at the pins you look at the
path through the pins you visualize the
path through the pins and I think
entrepreneurships a lot like that like
once once you can't visualize not doing
it you're just like well I'll just find
a way I don't know the way yet but I
will find it there there's always a
solution there's always a path through
the pins a little bit the last question
is aliens talk about the future believer
or non-believer in an alien's
potentially existing I guess for the
most part I'm a believer
because I think that really that's a
question of how big do you think the
universe is and if you think the
universe is really large it becomes
approaching a hundred percent
probability that there's intelligent
life somewhere and it's weird it's like
if you think that the universe is
infinite then by definition you have to
believe there's in fact you have to
believe that infinity kind of blows your
mind when you really think about because
like the conversation we're having right
now is happening an infinity number of
times somewhere cuz that's infinity
you've hit on exactly why I asked that
question which is I actually don't care
about the answer to the question is how
people work through what their answer is
right and you really can see the way
that somebody thinks about it's similar
to my brother worked at an investment
bank and he's you know he goes to the
interview and I ask him how many golf
balls go it you know in a 747 right he's
all right you know basically they don't
care what the your actual answer they
want to see how do you mentally get
there right because the process is more
important than the actual result to some
degree yep yeah all right to finish up
what one question do you have for me oh
boy and I hope this isn't an unoriginal
hackneyed question do you think that the
dollar is a bubble that will collapse in
our lifetime this is the hundred
trillion dollar question so soon to be
more yeah yeah basically here's my
general thought I'm gonna give you two
scenarios and then I'll try to put a
weight of confidence of them playing out
the first scenario is coexistence of a
nation state backed global reserve
currencies like we have now coexisting
with a very popular separation of state
and money let's call it Bitcoin right
and so to me that is something that
looks like the United States and many of
its
trading partners end up continuing on
the status quo actually it may get
deeper entrenched actually but then
there are some maybe smaller countries
or countries who are not friends with
the United States that end up saying hey
look let's get off this system and go
our own way this non-sovereign thing is
interesting to us and so that
coexistence is kind of a path one path
to is one that is much more adversarial
and actually there is a the nation-state
currencies fail you know whatever that
ends up looking like and then you get
this non-sovereign thing on option one I
put a very high degree or a high
probability so I don't know exact
numbers but more than 50% likely that
there's at least coexistence of fiat and
a non-sovereign currency that's used
with some degree of popularity when it
comes to the adversarial nature I
actually think it's this weird thing
where somebody once said to me most
thing most great things in life aren't
something until they are right and and
and that's a weird saying but but I
think it really applies here in that
it's a hundred and sixty billion dollar
asset right now right I think most
people are looking at this like what is
this toy that these people on Twitter
and reddit are talking about right and
even though we're 11 years in and had
the performances had like like it still
doesn't matter to some degree that will
continue for I actually think you know
could be five or ten more years maybe
even longer and then all of a sudden it
really really matters right and so
ultimately this gets out the question
that you're asking which is does the
dollar fail right can the US default and
I have a framework in my head which I
don't know is actually accurate but I
think it's at least interesting so if
you think of in history every currency
that's failed each one of them basically
were replaced as global reserve currency
because another country invaded or used
military might to establish superiority
right and so no Rome Falls okay somebody
else gets to put their
is the global reserve currency and
really its military might and so that's
what the United States has and that's
why the dollar has continued to as it
has but that is all in the the physical
world right in the digital world it's
not so much actually who has the most
offense it's actually who has the best
defense right and the example I use is
his you know if the United States hacks
into China's electrical grid we only can
create damage until they kick us out
right then we got to get back in again
but if they just never let us in the
defense actually makes you more powerful
than the offense and so in some weird
way
Bitcoin having the strongest computing
network in the world has the best
defense in the digital world and it has
no offense actually right so it's like
100% defense 0% offense and about a year
ago I wrote this thing and I said you
know it would be to steal a line from a
Jeff Lewis over at bedrock it would be a
narrative violation to think that a
global reserve currency could reach that
level of superiority without having an
offense right without having military
might and so that's like a framework to
me that is less about the dollar failing
and more about like the game theory of
people just slowly opting into this
thing that has the non-sovereign element
to it so on a probability of the US
dollar feeling like it's scary right
like at the end of the day it's just
like what does that world look like I
have an opinion but but like that is a
really scary development and it's not
obvious that Bitcoin as a hedge against
it hold a whole nother you know thing
right of like you could actually be
right that it happens but be wrong on
what the solution is right that's right
when you get into this I do think this
is like the big question right and so
today I actually wrote a thing that said
you know the Treasury is gonna borrow
three trillion dollars from April to
June of this year and so I explained you
know kind of Treasury bonds work but I
said is it really debt if they're never
gonna pay it back and not so much not
pay back the bond
that they're gonna issue for there's
three shorting dollars but the federal
debt
there's no path whatsoever I don't care
what your political belief is I don't
care both sides of the aisle nobody has
the intention nor the plan to actually
pay back you know what will end up being
twenty eight trillion dollars at the end
of this year it's like you know you get
into this game of like well they can't
really default because they could print
whatever they want what does that
actually accelerate the failure of the
currency and you know so the concern I
have about it all is if you think about
bubbles they're really usually a
psychosocial phenomenon and it's it's
something where nobody believes that it
could ever happen so that'll keep going
and I think that the average person I
know just believes the dollar be here
forever
but but the problem is it failing is
such a Black Swan event with such
profound consequences that first of all
it would be terrible
and and second of all it's like the the
fact that nobody believes it can happen
makes me more concerned that it could
you know can I ask you one another
question
yeah before I let you do one other thing
I want to say on this that that you made
me think of is there's a lot of funds
that obviously you know they basically
lose a little bit of money every month
betting on the Black Swan happening and
then when it happens they make a killing
right so there's an opportunity cost to
doing it but the risk reward exists the
one thing about the dollar failing so
let's say Bitcoin would be the solution
there's almost no opportunity cost to
making the hedge to do that right
because you can you know again going
back to that coexistence where you can
actually be pseudo short the dollar by
simply being long the other asset but it
cost you nothing in that and so that's
an interesting kind of caveat because
normally you would have some opportunity
cost there yeah yeah so and that and
that's to me the best argument for
buying
coin is in the case of the
extraordinarily rare event and the
dollar is above all it's the most
logical thing to go up or at least be
worth what it's worth
yeah and I always tell people to like
the part that scares me is like the a
lot of people in the the crypto world a
car like the financialization of Bitcoin
I'm not worried about like the
infrastructure or the people who come in
it's the narrative and what scares me is
like Bitcoin is such a binary thing it's
either gonna be worth tons and tons in
u.s. dollar you know terms or is gonna
be worth zero right and when you start
to financial eyes it it then becomes
into you know hey when up 10% like the
10% doesn't matter right cuz that
because if you hold this for a long
period of time it's either going you
know way higher or it's going to zero
and that risk profile I think is really
hard for people to wrap their heads
around as well so I don't know what you
said there's one another question yeah
so you know as someone who follows
crypto pretty closely what do you think
are the technology inflections that
might cause a massive acceleration of
adoption in crypto cuz like most people
they'll say well people don't believe XY
and Z I'm like okay great I get that but
like just humor me is there technology
inflection what do you think so I have
kind of a two-part answer so one is we
already had it write it with with the
actual invention of Bitcoin and
something solving the double spend
problem and that was such a leap forward
that really empowered all of this right
if we don't get that we don't see you
know any of this really happen so I
think that was kind of sticking point
one the second one is I haven't thought
enough about it to exactly articulate it
but but it's the layer 2 layer 3 you
know and above right so I always go to
gold and the dollar where you have gold
bars one of the big you know quote
technology inflection points
was the creation of paper claims on the
gold right and and and as people started
to adopt that you know technology it
made all the transactions easier it made
everything around pricing easier like
everything changed because now you were
able to use the currency better
ultimately we don't think of it as a
technology inflection point but it was
right we went from carrying physical
precious metals to now you had a piece
of paper that was a IOU or a claim on
that I think that there's something like
that there's some people who are trying
right so obviously lightning Network
liquid would block stream like there I
think directionally correct
are they the correct implementation of
the technology that's remains to be seen
but I do feel like there are elements
that get built on layer 2 that
completely changed this and it empowers
the transactions it empowers the ability
to price things in BTC you know and
really what it does is it sucks a lot of
people in because that technology
inflection point in some weird way
almost like expands the market of people
who are willing to use this you you go
from like the really hardcore early
adopters to now you get something that
looks more useable to a much wider
audience right yeah because like what
I've wondered about is so for better or
worse I'm an amateur cinematographer
right and like 4k video will just bring
any computer in its knees and so I've
got this Mac that has this card in it
called an afterburner card and it's this
FPGA that's purpose-built to like just
tear through ProRes video and I mean it
just it it's not just faster it's like
super fast like crazy fast and I wonder
if someday in smartphones or some type
of ubiquitous device there might be a
chip someday that's low cost enough that
now you can calculate make make
consensus protocol calculations way more
efficiently
you're way more distributed or just way
better somehow like that's the kind of
stuff I'm looking for is like what's the
what's this thing where it's like oh man
now that now that we have that you're
the equivalent of an afterburner in
everybody's phone but for Bitcoin or for
aetherium whatever so but one thing I
would say to this and I project I'm
thinking a little bit out loud here so
one of the things that I thought like
the Ark of discovery of Bitcoin so
people come in to hear about Bitcoin
right usually there's about price so
they come and they see that then there's
like enterprise blockchain then there's
like the I co stuff and you gotta go
throughout the entire industry and some
majority portion of people come back and
say okay this Bitcoin thing is real what
you have to go explore the other things
intellectually to kind of see that value
so if you then go okay well what is it
about Bitcoin that is that kind of zero
to one or that inflection point there's
for sure the technology of solving the
the double spend problem but actually
there's plenty of other technology
platforms that are using either
blockchain or distributed letters or
technology that are faster they can you
know process more transactions all those
kind of stuff but the reason why Bitcoin
continues to win is not a technology
problem right and there's people who
will say like money's not a technology
problem
it's a monetary policy problem right and
so the one thing that I do wonder and
and I don't have an answer I wish that I
did is like money the one asset slash
opportunity where the technological
advantage is actually mute if you don't
have the monetary policy cost
superiority right or advantage there and
so it's interesting to think you because
I don't know yeah yeah I mean to me
bitcoin is just one of the most amazing
it you know I mean I don't have to tell
you this right you just go down infinite
rabbit holes but like what I what I find
particularly inspiring about it is a lot
of the early network effects companies
that invested in after the fact have
problems with abuse or have problems
with you know unintentional
consequences of the platform and what to
me was brilliant about Bitcoin is that
government the government's effective
government's was an emergent property of
the protocol and so the the the networks
that I'm excited about the future are
those that have government's embedded is
just like the US has a constitution you
know I think that Network capitalist
enterprises are not the same as
vertically integrated corporations and
networked capitalist enterprises because
they have co-creation and production
with their customers it's it's a lot
likes it starts to look more like
citizens in a country and you kind of
say look you know for us to all get the
most out of this we have to agree on set
of rules upfront and what the boundaries
and guardrails are and they're not
intended to restrict people but they're
tended to make it not in the interests
of bad actors act badly and like to me
like some type of a government strategy
is really important for AI and some of
these things that are coming on the
horizon we're getting it wrong is gonna
be way more costly than Twitter spam
yeah the thing that uh you know relating
back to our earlier conversation is like
the insight that a technology solution
to governance across a whole bunch of
applications feels like a no-brainer
there are people out there who have
thought you know a hundred times more
and longer and deeper about what are
those specific applications how do you
actually productize them than I have and
the one thing that I do go back to is on
that governance it's not only like the
actual consensus mechanism right but
there's also this weird element of how
the votes are cast or it says one way of
like like you know how do you count the
votes and sure there's not fraud and all
that kind of stuff but in this you know
you can almost imagine a world where
we're gonna have big problems in the
future if the quote unquote governance
of something is hey ten of us are gonna
get on skype or zoom and I happen to
have really good deep fakes right and I
can cast votes and all this kind of
stuff
the beauty of Bitcoin is the proof
work is really really hard to manipulate
or or fake I don't know if that's the
answer for every single application of
governance in the future right there's
plenty of people who are detractors of
it whatever for money it feels like the
right one but as you get into something
like more akin to a network governance
or you know corporate governance are
there some of these other solutions that
will work probably I just know that like
hey I'm not smart enough to figure that
out and so I'd much rather go find
somebody who you know is the expert and
feels like they've got the solution and
then let them kind of do their magic so
can I be greedy and ask one more
question I could talk to you all day so
so so like the other thing I've been
thinking about lately is you know you
have these computing waves so when my
dad was at IBM there were mainframes and
then the PC came out and processing
power went from super expensive like
when my dad came back from Vietnam
working for IBM they used to call it the
IBM room and they had guys and lab coats
and everything was about keep the
mainframe running and don't screw it up
right and then and then all of a sudden
microprocessors come out computing
becomes free value migrates of
proprietary software of Microsoft Oracle
companies like that then the internet
happens and communications bandwidth
starts to become progressively free and
value migrates from proprietary software
software becomes open-source and it
becomes who's the single source supplier
of certain types of data right so you
get Google Facebook Amazon all having
this massive advantage in data and so if
you if you if you subscribe to the
theory of evolution of computing
technology you would say people in
software and technology are so smart and
there's so many of them and they just
keep coming that someday data is going
to go from being proprietary to
commoditized and so part of part of what
also got me excited initially out
blockchain or even blockchain inspired
ideas was this idea the data would be
commoditized and rather than owned by
single companies would be pushed out to
the edge and
by we the people and then and then it
seems in that world governance becomes
now the valuable scarce resource right
so it's another little bit of a twist on
it and that's if you believe in crypto
through the lens of not just money
crypto but also software or crypto and
you know tech crypto which sometimes I
get offend people when I say I might
believe yeah it's a weird thing we're
like so if you said to me what is one
you know view of the world or of the
future that I think is a it's a foregone
conclusion at this point what I don't
know is how somebody will build that
actual solution it's this idea of us
owning data but to me what you're
actually doing is less about like you
owning the data and it's more about
removing the middleman right which is
right now you actually create a bunch of
data right so it's whether apples got
all the steps you took your heart rate
you know Facebook Facebook has where you
win you checked in or what photos you
uploaded just go down the you know
Twitter's got your thoughts whatever it
is they've done a great job of
collecting all of that anonymizing
aggregating and they don't really sell
the data necessarily but they really do
they sell targeting with the data right
and they've all done a great job of of
monetizing well in a world where you
hold that data really all you're doing
is you're shifting the revenue from
somebody else to you the question
becomes how lucrative is that how do you
change behavior how do you automate it
to some degree right like I don't think
Mike's gonna sit there and say oh okay
somebody sent me an email and wants to
pay me three dollars and 20 cents to get
my you know steps today approve so I
think it's you know you you kind of get
into the details of how do you actually
execute on it and I don't know what that
looks like but to me there's governance
there and there's this this idea of just
sovereignty right and the internet
really democratized stuff and then I
think you'll get some sovereignty on the
back end of this that that'll end up
being incredibly valuable as well okay
cool well anything else we should talk
about I would probably go all day for an
out here
listen.you you've been incredibly
gracious with your time I always enjoyed
talking so thanks for doing this we will
we'll send people to the podcast and go
check you out on Twitter cuz you're
tweeting up a storm which I enjoy saying
yeah I've been playing with tweet storms
lately but um yeah Anthony I really
appreciate your having me on the show it
was fun it's always fun to talk to you
you're one of the first guys as well to
spend any time with me when I was
starting to look into crypto and always
be grateful for that
I'm gonna embarrass you for two seconds
because you're the only person who came
to me this is pretty early I you you
were one of the first when I consider a
more traditional venture capitalist who
reached out to me and I walked away from
our meeting and I said he's the only
person who brought up pen and actually
took notes so I know he was listening
right everyone else wanted like you know
kind of [ __ ] or shoot the [ __ ] and
they walked away and I was just like I
have no clue if they they even got
anything on the conversation and I
remember when you walked out and you had
notes I said you know what I don't know
if he'll he'll agree with it or not
agree with it but I can guarantee you
that he actually understood what was
always going on oh yeah I've still got
him
yes I've got him from this podcast today
yeah all right well I appreciate a Mike
and I hope everyone really enjoys this
all right thanks Anthony appreciate the
time